bonjour à tous et bon jour avoue
isabelle florelle je voudrais justement
qu'on revienne sur la situation en
gironde ces incendies avec la première
ministre le ministre de l'intérieur qui
iront sur place la gironde c'est la
première la plus ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'elle est ravagée par les flammes est
ce que vous pensez qu'on a les moyens
humains matériels de lutte et
aujourd'hui contre ces incendies on les
a on il faut souligner il faut remercier
et surtout
ses pompiers qui sont depuis le début du
mois de juillet mobilisés c'est
important que le ministre est la
première ministre se rende à leurs côtés
et en soutien aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'il faut une mobilisation ce cas des
ministres de l'intérieur aussi de la
réserve
des pompiers en france il ya certains
qui proposent aux entreprises de libérer
ceux qui sont pompiers volontaires pour
qu'ils aillent sur le front des
incendies ça ça peut être une bonne
piste pour trouver rapidement justement
des pompiers supplément cdc des relais
surtout par rapport à l'épuisement que
connaissent les pompiers j'imagine
actuellement parce qu'à un certain
nombre de régions sont touchées
évidemment il ya la gironde mais il ya
d'autres régions il ya l'isère et
d'autres encore qui sont très en
surveillance donc forcément énormément
de personnes et on a besoin de personnel
on a besoin de les former on a besoin de
travailler sur ces questions comme l'a
fait d'ailleurs le le parlement sur les
questions de la réserve des pompiers et
des pompiers réservistes moi je crois
qu'il faut il faut les soutenir il faut
encourager cette mobilisation citoyenne
mais rien ne remplace évidemment les
professionnels sur le terrain et surtout
leur permettent d'avoir un peu de repos
de reprendre des forces parce que lutter
comme on le voit en gironde depuis des
semaines contre ces incendies
malheureusement souvent d'origine
criminelle c'est cet énorme depuis le
mois de juillet donc encore un grand
coup de chapeau dire que toutes les
bonnes volontés
évidemment sont les bienvenus et que
nous les encouragerons et que c'est un
devoir aussi des citoyens et la
population que d'être en vigilance de
toute façon que l'ensemble de la
population soit aussi en vigilance vous
avez parlé effectivement de ces
incendies trop souvent criminels
malheureusement mis le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin disait qu'il
ya de grande suspicion que le feu qui a
repris en gironde soit le fait d'un
incendiaire est-ce qu'il va falloir
renforcer notre arsenal juridique pour
lutter aussi contre tous ces pompiers
pyromanes parfois ou en tout cas ces
personnes qui à un moment donné allume
le feu de manière volontaire ou pas
d'ailleurs il ya il ya déjà un arsenal
juridique vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs
qui existe et qui est qui est important
maintenant je crois qu'il ya un devoir
d'éducation citoyenneté à renforcer un
devoir qui est à faire je dis aussi bien
par les professionnels que par
l'ensemble des citoyens et des communes
pour justement ce prêt va agir en
prévention je crois parce que l'arsenal
juridique il est déjà assez important
maintenant c'est de la prévention c'est
un travail de terrain avec les élus
locaux et puis évidemment avec toutes
les forces je vous le disais un tous les
citoyens qui doivent être mobilisés sur
ces questions du effectivement aussi un
votre précédente invité en parler un
climat et un dérèglement climatique dont
il faut avoir conscience donc tout ça
c'est une prise de conscience aussi
citoyenne qui doit se faire et je crois
que là-dessus l'ensemble des élus
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre est
mobilisée moi je pense que l'arsenal
existe on peut toujours sûrement
l'améliorer mais je crois pas que c'est
une loi qui va changer les choses là
c'est vraiment de la prévention à faire
un tout autre sujet sur lima meet you
scène ça y est le ministère de
l'intérieur a déposé le recours devant
le conseil d'état il y a quelques jours
gérald darmanin se disait plutôt serein
sur l'issue de cette décision il a
raison mise aux intérieurs de penser que
le conseil d'état peut lui donner raison
en tout cas je souhaite
nous le souhaitons modem que nous
puissions avec le ministre puisse aller
au bout de cette démarche
d'expulsion compte tenu des propos qui
ont été tenus par l'imam et de ce qui
est connu depuis ces derniers mois le
concernant donc on souhaite que la
justice et le conseil d'état puisse
aller dans le sens du ministre en tout
état de cause si ce n'était pas le cas
je crois que là il y à vraiment pour le
coup à revoir la loi pour le coup il
faudra
je pense dans le débat sur sur
l'immigration est en tout cas sur le
débat sur que nous devons avoir sur ces
questions là il faudrait si la justice
administratif ne va pas dans le sens du
ministre la revoir les critères et
revoir la loi parce que les propos tenus
par l'imam sont extrêmement dangereux et
met en cause les valeurs et les
principes de notre république donc là
pour le coup je nous serions
extrêmement vigilants et nous
demanderions au ministre de pouvoir
changer les critères et changer la loi
pour lui donner raison parce que les
propos sont choquants et et touche aux
principes fondamentaux de notre de notre
cohésion républicaine un mot de ce qui
se passe à grenoble eric piolle persiste
et signe il estime qu'on pourra quand
même malgré l'avis du conseil d'état se
baigner en burkini ou bien seins nus
dans les piscines municipales
comment on fait pour qu eric piolle
respecte la décision du conseil d'état
est ce qu'il faut le sanctionner
moi je pense que là il ya
de toute façon une autorité aussi
préfectoral qui devrait se prononcer je
pense que ça sur le département il ya un
préfet et peut toujours se prononcer et
sûr sûr sûr la question de l'accès à la
piscine le maire de grenoble est violent
il n' est pas à sa première tentative
de faire parler de lui et de se mettre
en dehors de notre république une fois
de plus une fois de plus en dehors des
principes c'est grave parce que avant
d'être un leader politique qu'il entend
est dans l'écologie même si à plusieurs
branches visiblement dans l'écologie
puisque on entend des avis différents
j'ai entendu un nouveau interlocuteur ce
matin dire qu'il était contre les
mesures d' eric piolle et c'est un maire
écologiste également donc il ya quand
même disparité de vue au sein des
écologistes sur cette question mais en
tout cas il se met il est premier
magistrat d'une ville avant d'être un
leader politique et je crois qui confond
une fois de plus son rôle le maire et
ben il doit être aussi garant des
principes républicains en light mais en
dehors des clous une fois de plus donc
je trouve ça et nous trouvons cela
aggrave il nous habitue régulièrement à
ses seuls 10 à ce type de clientélisme
qui est qui est redoutable et on voit
les dégâts que ça peut provoquer le
rejet que ça provoque dans une partie de
la communauté française un mot aussi de
la proposition de sacha oublier le
président de la commission des lois qui
voudraient pouvoir accorder le droit de
vote et de se présenter aux élections
municipales aux étrangers hors union
européenne
on voit bien que ça divise déjà la
classe politique quelle est la position
du modem sur cette proposition le modem
a toujours pensé qu'il fallait prendre
le débat de plus largement mais ça pose
de questions et ça fait déjà des années
mais récemment depuis deux ans que nous
travaillons sur ces questions ça pose
deux questions c'est la question de
l'accès à la citoyenneté française d'un
d'une partie des français des étrangers
et la deuxième question c'est la lutte
contre l'abstention et là vraiment sont
deux sujets sur lesquels nous souhaitons
travailler mais c'est vous voyez c'est
une question plus large le focus
uniquement de l'axé du droit de vote aux
étrangers nous semble trop restreint
faut agir plus largement agir sur la
naturalisation sûrement pour des
étrangers qui n'ont pas fait ces
démarches les accueillir mieux les
accueillir quand effectivement ils sont
là depuis longtemps médias la démarche
de naturalisation qu'il faut peut-être
mieux faire connaître parce qu'un
certain nombre ne la font pas et donc
encourager cette naturalisation puis une
deuxième chose très important et qui
nous semblent nous essentiel c'est de
faciliter l'accès aux votes de permettre
aux citoyens c'est pas normal aux
dernières élections présidentielles aux
dernières élections --législatives plus
de la moitié des français ne se sont pas
rendus aux urnes et là il ya un vrai
travail etc ça pour nous pour le modem
la question la plus importante c'est de
ramener les citoyens ramener les
citoyens français la première des choses
vers le vote vers les votes aux
élections nationales évidemment mais
vers le vote aux élections locales on
voit trop de taux d'abstention depuis
une quarantaine d'années augmenté et là
il ya une vraie démarche faciliter
l'inscription mais également facilité il
ya une proposition de loi qui vient
d'être déposée pour permettre
l'inscription automatique
bon ben voilà ça c'est des sujets sur
lequel il faut qu'on travaille à un
conseil national de la refondation qui
va s'ouvrir au mois de septembre sous
l'égide d'olivier ferrand et je souhaite
que ces questions démocratiques en tout
cas le travail a été fait les rapports
existait une mission qui est encore
rendu il ya quelques mois l'assemblée
nationale un travail sur la question de
l'abstention vraiment pour nous au modem
c'est vraiment la question principale la
question de en faire revenir les
français aux urnes je pense que voyez
c'est plus large que cette simple
proposition de loi il faut avoir une
démarche plus large mais si il n'y a
entre guillemets que ça qui est présente
et si elle est présenté de telle manière
est ce que les députés modem pourrait
voter cette proposition ou alors vous
dites on ne vote pas parce que justement
ça ne va pas assez loin ça n'est pas
dans une démarche assez large je ne peux
pas me prononcer sans qu'il y ait un
débat au sein du groupe il y aura des
bas mais en tout état de cause les
députés modem ferons des propositions
plus larges que celles simple pour
enrichir cette proposition en tout cas
tel quel je ne vois pas comment nous
pourrions
être complètement d'accord on voit bien
qu'il y aura un débat d'un débat au sein
du groupe renaissance qui aura un débat
au sein du groupe edf et un débat au
sein de l'assemblée ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'ouvrir cette
question démocratiques dans les mois qui
viennent merci beaucoup à isabelle
floren porte parole du modem